good evening welcome to the academy
Museum of motion pictures the largest
institution in the United States for the
Arts science and Artisan movie making
the academy Museum Motion Pictures
acknowledges the tongva people as the
traditional caretakers of the water and
land on which we program curate educate
convene and discuss
we honor and respect tongv ancestors at
the tongva community today which
continue to nurture this land in water
through traditional practice activism
art and education
we also acknowledge that continued work
to safeguard cultural resources
my name is Robert Renault and I'm the
specialist in the film programs
Department here at the Museum
thank you for joining us on our David
Geffen Theater for the documentary
features nominees panel presented as
part of our Oscar week programming
before we begin the panel we'd like to
know the public programming for 2023
Oscar week is made possible by the
rudeman Family Foundation which wrote
its authentic representation in the
entertainment industry and full
inclusion of people with disabilities
throughout all sectors of society
I would also like to thank our ASL
interpreters who'll be assisting today
their names are felix Villarreal Richard
Loya and Pala Morales
now please help me in welcoming to the
stage senior vice president of member
relations Global Outreach and awards
Administration Tom oyer
assistant
hi everyone good to see you all thank
you all for coming I'm here representing
the member relations and awards team
today uh today we are celebrating
obviously our five documentary feature
Film nominees and you might be asking
well how did we get here well I'll give
you the breakdown of the process the
awards process involves a number of
steps the first step is the films need
to qualify in order for a documentary
feature film to qualify there's two
methods to qualification one is based
off of its uh theatrical release in one
of a number of our qualifying cities the
Phil can complete a one-week qualified
run in order to be eligible the other
method is we have a qualifying Festival
process by which we have festivals from
around the world where certain awards at
those festivals make the films
automatically eligible to be submit and
be eligible in the category uh the
second step of the process the films
need to submit there's a whole
submission process it's a fun time let
me tell you and uh through that
submission process uh the films that are
provided to the academy I want to give a
special thank you to Michael Benedict
Lauren fee and many others on our team
the academy team here that uh helped
make that entire submission process
possible
that all right there we go thank you
uh so then once we get all our
submissions then there's the voting
process and this this begins our lovely
voting process with the documentary
Branch members uh we provide uh films to
the document Branch members throughout
the year as films are qualifying and
submitting to us uh they are there's
different assigned viewing there's a
whole process by which they are watching
all the films that are up for
consideration in both of the documentary
categories throughout that process goes
into the fall and then in December we
have a short list of voting first round
of voting to determine a short list in
December uh that short list is 15 films
in the category
from there then we do a second round of
voting in January to narrow down the 15
films to the five nominees today I'm not
five nominees that you have here today
again documentary Branch members
determine that uh those nominees from
there then we go out to the entire
Academy membership the entire membership
votes on all 23 categories determining
the Oscar winner in each category which
you'll find out on Sunday
so um I wanted to take a moment to just
really thank all the academy members
that put all their time in viewing films
and all the different categories but of
course I'm thanking the documentary
Branch members for all the work they do
I it's so appreciated and will continue
to enlist your help every year
um next I would like it's my pleasure to
introduce you three wonderful members of
the documentary Community who I have had
to have the pleasure of working with all
year round not just during Oscar season
uh the three documentary Branch
Governors Kate amend Chris heginess and
Gene Chen
good evening my name is Jean Chen this
is my second year as the governor of the
documentary branch and on behalf of 650
documentary Branch members I want to
thank Tom Warrior and Michael Bennett
for all the hard work they do to keep us
afloat and I'm going to introduce our
newest Governor Chris hijedith legendary
filmmaker
Eugene I'm the newest member but
probably one of the oldest persons
working in film here and I'm so honored
to be part of the academy and celebrate
this awesome talented group of
filmmakers tonight who've made such
inspiring films and I'd like to
introduce
Kate and men who has served the academy
for nine years and this is her last
event here at the Academy and I'm really
so grateful for all of her tutoring for
me in the academy
thank you Chris and Gene and Tom and
Michael
this is always such a wonderful night to
celebrate the incredible documentaries
that are nominated this year
I'm old enough to remember watching the
Oscars with my mom and dad on our black
and white television
in the living room
and I also remember that in those days
the men all wore white tie and Tails to
to the Oscars but one
and Bob Hope was always the host the MC
but one fond memory I have is this one
time when Bert Lancaster and Kirk
Douglas sang a song
in their white tying Tails did a little
song of Dance
called it's great not to be nominated
and they did a whole routine about not
being nominated well I'd like to say
that it is great to be nominated
and these incredible filmmakers you're
going to meet tonight have all produced
masterpieces really these are incredible
powerful important
impactful films and it's
the whole year has been very strong for
documentaries
um
and there were some that were not
nominated that were pretty wonderful too
but these five films are just stunning
and I know you're going to enjoy hearing
from these brilliant filmmakers so thank
you and I'd like to introduce our
moderator tonight who is KJ Ralph Miller
who's the
associate director of film programs here
at the Museum
so KJ
[Applause]
thank you so much Chris Jean Kate
so this is the first year that we are
presenting Oscar week panels at the
Museum and we are so excited to
celebrate the Oscars and all our
nominees here today in the David Geffen
Theater which I may be biased but I
think is the best movie theater in Los
Angeles
yeah some people agree
um so my name is KJ Ralph Miller and as
the associate director of film programs
here at the Museum it is my extreme
privilege to be part of a wonderful team
who together produce over 400 screenings
each year both in this space and in our
wonderful Ted Mann Theater all of which
are like today presented for the public
since I started my film career in the
documentary non-profit space I as a film
programmer remain dedicated to the
preservation the restoration and the
exhibition of yes Cinema of all forms
but from any era but really especially
to shining a light on significant and
underscreened documentary films from
across cinematic history we're thrilled
to this summer be presenting a
three-month-long program that we're
calling summer of Music which is
dedicated to the rich history of the
concert film and that's just one of the
examples of the ways in which the
academy Museum's film programs will
continue to Champion documentary films
and filmmakers throughout our year-round
programming and tonight is no exception
for their support of the Museum's
exhibitions programs and numerous other
initiatives and in particular for
helping to orchestrate Oscar week here
at the Museum I want to first thank
Academy president Janet Yang and the
academy CEO Bill Kramer I also want to
thank the academy Museum's president and
director Jacqueline Stewart our chief
audience officer Amy Hama Eduardo
Sanchez silver Feldman Christina yabara
Tom oyer and dilcia Barrera thank you
all for your tireless efforts and
dedication to making this incredible
week of celebrations possible
so before I bring out our nominees I
would like to ask our ASL interpreters
to please take the stage
and now please allow me to introduce our
nominees for best documentary feature
film
for navalny Daniel Rohr Odessa Ray Diane
Becker and Melanie Miller
[Applause]
also nominated for navalny is Shane
Boris I would like to introduce Shane
Boris as a producer of navalny as well
as a producer of fire of Love along with
the director Sarah doser Dosa and
producer Aina fichman
from a house made of splinters Simon
Lorraine Wilmont and Monica hellstrom
[Applause]
from all the Beauty and the Bloodshed
Yoni golekhov
John Lyons Howard gertler
and Nan golden
from all that breathes shonak sen Amman
Mon and Teddy Leifer
[Applause]
thank you all so much for being here
this evening and for making these
tremendous films
um Each of which is I think
um so much of this moment and in others
recall a not so distant past that is
made ever more immediate by your
thoughtful Conjuring of these stories
into relatable Frameworks and contexts
and so I would like to start with the
directors for each film and just ask how
you came to your subjects and I think in
some cases this could be an overarching
theme or event and in others it's an
individual and we can start with all
that breathes
thank you it's lovely to be here
um in our case it actually began with
um an interest in thinking of air
and if you live in Delhi you're always
preoccupied with what you're breathing
in in a way and
I was also philosophically interested in
thinking of human non-human
relationships
um
more than anything else I think I was
interested in a kind of tone or texture
of a kind of vaporous smokiness
and uh this one time when Aman and I
were in a car and
um Aman suddenly looked a bit surprised
and uh we looked up and realized that we
were seeing a bird falling off the sky
and um in a way that sort of nudged the
film uh into some kind of uh existence
and then once we met the main characters
in this small cramped basement it sort
of takes on a life of its own but I
don't know it's really difficult to talk
about where it began it began as a kind
of interest in a texture of life in the
city
and for all the Beauty and the Bloodshed
I know Laura could not be here this
evening but uh perhaps Nan if you would
like to talk about
um finding Laura and starting to work
together on this film
so we started the film ourselves the
group pain for a year and a half before
Laura came on
and
yeah it was
the three of us there were three of us
working constantly on the movie so we
had a lot of material and we hadn't
really formatted it and
then Laura came on and every I was very
scared of working with Laura portraits I
thought you know I don't have any
secrets you know I don't have any big uh
political secrets to reveal and why is
she interested in me
and it started as a film about pain the
group I started to fight the
pharmaceutical companies and the
families behind them the family behind
them
and then it branched out into work I had
done during the AIDS crisis I curated
the first big show of eight about AIDS
with 12 of members of my community
and she became very interested in that
and I introduced her to some of the
crucial people of the times that I grew
up in like David Warner robich and Greer
Langton and David Armstrong and so the
film started to evolve then during covid
she would come over and interview me
and the interviews were very deep in
penetrating and she became interested in
my sister
and that's how that evolved so what's
great about the film is the way she
weaves the personal and the political
together
and it's a real collaboration because I
also worked on the material
and uh had a lot of say in what was used
so it's kind of a collaborative film
yeah and both of your voices are present
we sometimes hear her speaking and
asking you questions and your voice is
obviously so present especially in in
your slide presentations
for a house made of Splinter Simon would
you like to discuss how you I guess
learned about this I don't want to say
orphanage but um
rehabilitation center for for these
children in in Ukraine
yeah
um previous to this film I made it
another documentary that was called the
distant backing of dogs which is about a
young young boy living along with his
grandma you know right near the front
line of the war in in Ukraine and during
the filming of that film I became very
close to this odd but wonderful couple
and in the later stages of shooting that
film
Alexandra the grandmother she became
very ill with some heart problems and I
realized that there would be no one left
to take care of him of the young kid
ulik if she were to pass away
luckily she didn't that they're going
they're still going strong and they're
living in the western parts of Ukraine
now
um but I kind of couldn't escape that
question do you know is this a problem
along the front line that kids are left
without anybody to take care of them
so um
I teamed up once again with my amazing
local assistant director asset safarov
and we began researching and very
quickly he actually came back and said
you know up near the Northern parts of
the then front line of the wall the city
Administration they saw your film and
they're they're actually welcoming you
so you can we can go and research if you
want to and I went
uh and to make a long story short I
visited a lot of places but but the the
first time I opened the door into
Margarita's shelter it was just so
obvious that there was something
completely different going on you know
it was little a little pace and it was
worn out but this younger kids were
running around in Ikea's and having fun
and there was a beautiful elderly lady
trying to teach some of the ghost music
even though she didn't really do music
herself I think and at the end of the
hallway was who I would later come to
know as Margarita and she was like
fiercely hugging two kids while she was
shouting angrily at some parent on the
phone you know and the whole place just
you know had this atmosphere of of
warmth and compassion and almost like a
real home and that was so different to
the other places that I visited that I
got very curious and that's how the film
started
and I have another question for you
later about specifically working with
children but Sarah I would love to hear
how you first learned about Katya and
Maurice sure first I just want to say
it's so wonderful to share this stage
with all of you I've had such a pleasure
of listening to each and every one of
you speak through this award season and
I'm just feeling a little emotional that
we're nearing the end so just thank you
all for continuing this journey together
um but I guess to answer your question I
have to pull myself back from emotion
uh for me I'm just fascinated by stories
similar to Sonic about the human
relationship with non-human nature
especially when there's a dimension
um of allegory or myth and so that's
always kind of in mind and actually when
Shane and our editor from prayer of Love
Aaron Casper and one of our producers
Elijah Stevens who I believe are also in
the audience today when we were
finishing up the last film that we made
together a film called the Sierra and
the Unseen we came across Katy and
Maurice that's because that film is a
verite documentary shot in Iceland which
is a volcanic island and we think of it
as a magically Real documentary we
wanted to open it with imagery archival
imagery of erupting volcanoes that could
really conjure this magical feeling of
this land that was constantly in
creation and destruction so we began
that process of archival research and
that's when we first learned about Katya
and racecraft because not that many
people had filmed erupting volcanoes in
Iceland
um once we saw the imagery we're just
instantly stunned by how gorgeous and
surreal it was but once we learned that
they were a married couple not just in
love with each other but also the Earth
that's when we thought wow there's a
really exciting story here and it had
that kind of Mythic Dimension that is
always particularly exciting to us
um so that's kind of how it all got
started and how we first met Katie and
Maurice
lovely and I have a question later about
um just the experience of digging
through that archive but we'll come back
to that
um Daniel I would love to hear how you
um first became interested in uh in
Alexi and and what led you to want to
make this this film about him and with
him
well I remember it was uh the summer of
2020 and I was at home in Toronto and I
was painting the wall of my apartment
and I was listening to the radio and
there was this extraordinary story of
this Russian opposition guy Alexia
navalny who at that moment was lying in
a hospital room somewhere in Siberia
apparently poisoned and the the Russian
government would wouldn't let him leave
and there was this sort of standoff
taking place and I registered that story
I knew who this guy was
cut to two and a half months later
my colleagues and I are working on a
completely different film and Odessa and
I find ourselves in Kiev or with Crystal
Groves of one of the investigative
journalists in our movie who we profile
and that film Project which is
completely different is not going well
and we are very assertively encouraged
to leave the country
so we find ourselves in Vienna Austria I
think it's October of 2020 and Crystal
comes in for a meeting one morning I'm
I'm disheveled and frustrated I don't
have a film to make it's the middle of a
pandemic I just keep hitting dead ends
and he sits down and he says we can't go
back to Kiev that film's finished but
there's something else you might be
interested in
and I was Furious I was so frustrated
and anxious and it's what Crystal what
is it and I'll never forget he sort of
leans in like he's telling me a state
secret and he says you know that navalny
guy I think I have a lead into who tried
to poison him and if it was a cartoon my
ears would have shot out and a light
bulb would have appeared above my head
and I popped up from my chair and I said
Crystal who's making that movie let's go
make that movie and he says okay should
I reach out to him I was like yeah reach
out to him and a week later
We snuck across the German Austrian
border Europe was closed from the
pandemic and we went to to pitch Alexa
and I had about five days to fully
Orient myself in everything I could
about this guy Russian Politics the
history of the Soviet Union everything
and I just had to be conversationally
fluent to be able to sit across from him
and Pitch him on not just why I should
make a film about him but why we should
make a film in general I had to convince
him as to why the medium mattered to him
and he should take it seriously and in
that first meeting when as we were
sitting across from the leader of the
Russian opposition who had recently
awoken from his coma we were able to
convince him and we started shooting the
film the next day
I'd love to hear I think you know some
folks here might be very familiar with
these processes but but for the general
public I love the idea of demystifying
the producing process for everyone
because I think that sometimes it's
shrouded in mystery and there's not
quite a concrete way of identifying
what's done the work of a producer and
so I would love to start with the
navalny team and hear from the producers
about how you first came on board and
started working with your filmmaker and
what key role you played in um in
starting the film or getting the film
finished
well I was on that crazy ride with
Daniel we were working in Kiev we got
kicked out we ended up in Vienna we got
a meeting and there was really no
question we just sort of went for it and
every day was absolutely exhausting we
had we embedded with navalny and the
family and had to basically just handle
everything and do everything
and die can continue
you were on the ground we were in La
wondering if you were safe
um and you know
at the end of 2020
when it became clear we had enough
material to make a movie
um the second question was like how
quickly can we make it and how much
money is it going to cost and can we get
it done independently or or whatnot and
it was at a time when you know we talked
to a sales agent and they said I don't
think anyone's going to really touch
this maybe one or two places and so we
had a meeting and we were kind of
reverse engineering it and going what is
the goal of this film and the goal was
to get the film done as quickly as
possible to you know spread alexei's
story and also to give ourselves a
platform to make sure that we had a
place that would be able to distribute
it properly you know the dissident had
come out that year and it had its own
difficulties so you know we just kept
coming back to CNN and CNN had been
reporting on the story and was very you
know aware of it obviously so you know
we were just like let's contact you know
Amy and tell us Courtney Sexton Alex
Hannibal and Ryan Robinson at CNN and
see what they think and we had a meeting
with them
um and the rest is history as they say
in that respect
I was definitely in charge of asking a
lot of security questions
we definitely use encrypted messaging
the entire time we actually moved our
edit around a lot on purpose uh just the
way we were encrypting drives and going
to different countries to actually edit
and you know I I joke but by the time we
actually had gotten into Sundance and
then we were working with CNN which is
also HBO Max but then also kind of
translates to part of Warner Brothers
the head of security for forensic like
marking at Warner Brothers offered me a
job
because of all the questions that I had
kind of run through with them say to
make sure that things were done properly
so um you know we kind of all take
different roles in this process and and
this is where I will hand it off to
Shane because he was a massive part of
the producing process as well
thanks yeah
um I I met Daniel in Toronto maybe six
or seven years ago and then was
reintroduced to him thanks to Sarah
three years ago uh I then connected
Daniel and Odessa who who we met thanks
to film Independence
um I met Diane and Mel thanks to
Sundance and Kristen Feeley in
particular we sort of assembled this
this um really incredible team from
early on and I was I was sort of the
last one to really fully come on board
to this film uh I'm a slow processor it
took me a while to sort of understand
the the it didn't take me any time at
all to understand the importance of the
film but it took me some time to
understand if if anything if there were
any gifts that I had to give to this
film but from from early on when Daniel
and Odessa were in the field Daniel and
I were having many conversations about
the kinds of questions we would be
asking Alexa and then from that point on
um we I started to contribute to the
team
um both yeah I think strategically and
helping to helping to listen to what the
film could be and and it's in its
fullest potential and try and always
incorporate and actualize the vision of
the film back into the film
great and would you like to also speak
on on fire of love and in your role
producing and then perhaps we can hear
from Aina also yeah
um sure uh this is Sarah and I have
worked in in different capacities in on
five or six six six films um and so when
when this idea for a fire of love when
we started to discuss it um we were just
blown away I think you know there as as
Sarah was discussed was was saying
earlier there's a there's a part in the
end of the film where we understand the
love triangle between Maurice Katya and
the volcanoes when we when we heard that
we sort of had a structure for the film
uh Sarah and I early on
um went on a kind of writing Retreat to
set up a treatment for the film and a
little structure that was then taken to
extraordinary places by Aaron casler and
Aaron Casper and Jocelyn ship who are
editors and Aina and I had had worked on
a previous project uh called stray and
we we assembled again this this
incredible team and I think for fire of
love it's it's a it was a different
process but but equally creative in the
sense of trying to search through the
material and discover what the story
could be
um and and really again listening to
Maurice and Katya as our guides and
following both the the facts of their
lives as we understood it but also
working to to fill in some of the gaps
that didn't exist in the archive to tell
the sort of Mythic quality of their
story
and I came on board as Shane said
because we you know we had known each
other through stray and I was a very big
fan of Sarah's previous films here in
the Unseen I thought it was absolutely
you know magnificent and I speak French
and one of the challenges of course of
of the film was finding the archive and
also negotiating for the archive which
was in this really wonderful archive
house in the southwest of France in Nazi
and you know the family had in
particular the brother who you know
we've we've met since and Sarah has You
Know spoken with many times about Tron
craft had bestowed this archive their
archived the 200 hours to this small
house who had taken care of it for many
years so they had only you know sold or
given parts of the archives to various
filmmakers they'd never had given the
opportunity to a filmmaker and film team
to actually make a film about the crafts
so that was my first contribution and
then of course we did we ended up doing
a lot of the post-production in Canada
and many of our team members are
actually coming here to the Oscars our
sound team we did the post our archival
producing came from Canada to from
Montreal and you know as you know we're
a french-speaking community even though
my first language is English so many of
us have worked in English and French and
this was kind of a natural fit and I
think it was a beautiful team you know
with Aaron and Jocelyn and and Elijah
and Sarah and Shane and our team in
Montreal it really it was really
something magical and an honor to be
part of this
thank you so much Monica I would love to
hear about
um how you first got involved in working
on house made of splinters so this is
our fourth film together
um
we started nearly 10 12 years ago work
on your first film and Samus made the
now four films about children and things
children are facing
um
and have to overcome
and yeah so I've been part of it from
the very beginning
um and I was just I thought it was such
a good idea to to carry on working
within Ukraine because this is where his
previous film The Distance back of dogs
took place and also we were able to work
with the same team again so we had a
Ukrainian team assat safaro and Lena
um
yeah
and and also so uh they were filming
there and we also worked I think that's
nice I can hear some of you are working
the same way that it's it's a
collaborations that you carry on with so
for distance back in dogs and X also the
two other films about children we worked
with our Swedish producer to be as
Jensen who's here today and also with
our Finnish producer Sammy
and it's like a typical European
co-production and I had a Ukrainian
producer as well that helped out but um
yeah the Ukrainian parts of the filming
um
and then of course I think the biggest
challenges with this film was that it's
a film about vulnerable children and you
had to get all the permissions to film
there and you know making sure that you
do everything in the right way
but because of Simon's experience with
working with children that's with we've
had a lot of experience from the
previous films so we just took it very
slowly and and and got it in the right
symbol
yes and I would love to come back to to
hearing a little bit more about working
with children but
um for the all the Beauty and the
Bloodshed team of producers which is all
all four of you
um I would just love to hear about your
individual involvement in in the film
yeah thank you and thank you so much for
having us um and it's great to be here
with everybody uh
I've worked with Laura for a long time
and in 2019 when when Nan and Laura they
had met before
um but when they reconnected and we were
all you know everybody was kind of
talking about this project that Nan and
as she said a few people had already
started
um Megan kapler who's a co-producer on
the film and in the film uh came to show
us some footage and she had she showed
us a little bit of the footage they had
of the private eye who was outside Nan's
house who was following them
and you know we saw that footage and the
footage of the of the actions and the
direct actions um and we just kind of
you know that's I was hooked um and you
know I think
um uh as you can see it takes a it takes
a really big team and there's even more
people um so I think a lot of producing
is just trying to you know coordinate
with a with a really big brilliant team
um brilliant archival producers and
co-producers uh shantia vergon and
Olivia Streisand music supervisor Don
Sutter Modell you know kind of at the
last minute you know adding the female
treble track
um from the John Waters film so things
like that uh every every little piece um
with with so many moving parts and so
many great people just kind of making
sure that we can get that all in and
finish the film
um which we did a couple times
you know when you
started this round of the conversation
you said the mystery the mystery of what
does the producer do
and I always think one of the most
fascinating things about it is
every single producer here answers that
completely differently and it's probably
the only job
in the production that isn't
tied to a very specific skill set or a
you know a guild guideline or a director
a cinematographer a wardrobe supervisor
a props person or something
and I think
the thing that's so fascinating about is
that everybody brings their own skill
set to it and strengths and then if
you're lucky you have
great Partners who enhance
when and make your weak areas stronger
and you bring your own kind of skill and
empathy empathy
and
emotion to it and so every producer does
the job differently and when people say
what does a producer do I think that's
why people are mystified by the job we
were incredibly lucky to have a great
group of people who all I think
complemented and enhanced
each other's skill sets and we were
odd
by devoted to and love Nan golden
which is easy to do but
it was a pleasure I heard that no it's a
it was a pleasure to come together and
tell this story
and I think just to add to this so much
of sometimes filmmaking is about it's
like finding your community and finding
your tribe as you make your way up and
we met Nan actually interviewing her for
another film
um that John and I are making with Rob
Epstein and Jeffrey Friedman about Nan's
friend Peter hujar the amazing
photographer uh and so Peter led us to
Nan and after that interview Nan said
you know I'm working on my own film with
pain and we could I could use your
advice and
um since uh Nan is our hero we were like
of course and so we started talking to
her about her film uh and you know I've
known John for like over 20 years from
when I was just starting out but I've
also known Laura for that long when we
were both working on the show split
screen for IFC and Nan happened to see
Laura a few days after the huchar and
the interview about Peter and and uh
mentioned the movie and then Laura
emailed me and said hey like I hear
you're talking to Nan and you know then
I'd be interested in directing so it
came to end with young me it came
together in a very organic Community
orientated way with a lot of love and
that's that's the movie
foreign
just the subject
no idea what a producer does none
I guess they um they yeah
they organize everything they raise the
money they keep it going I've got very
close to Howard and John
and love them dearly and uh you know it
wasn't an easy film for anybody
honestly so we made it through and uh
yeah I hope to keep working with them
so I'm not really a producer I'm an I'm
an editor and I brought in
um my my friend's soundwalk to compose
the score and I worked in this actually
worked in the studio in Berlin with them
on the score so I got involved in every
part of the film
and uh I'm proud of that
I'm hearing a lot of support system uh I
think that that's kind of a common thing
but um Aman and Teddy I would love to
hear how you provided a support system
for your filmmaker and I know that you
seanick you were also a producer on this
film too so if you'd like to speak to
that as well
well we've known each other pretty much
our entire adults lives and we'd work
together on his first film so in here
this idea inspired by this whole
concept of the texture of delhi's air we
just began working together at that
point and on our first one we hadn't
produced it and then the problem was
that we didn't really have much of a say
in terms of
how we could distribute it or in terms
of fundraising so here we just decided
that we were going to produce this and
it's well almost like a little little
bit of an accident because I
think I end up with the producer title
because I know how to work Excel
spreadsheets yes
but then the first year we had like a
really tiny team often it was to seanick
and me he was shooting I was doing sound
and just building that relationship with
our characters and then two other
members of the same directing team from
the first film and then we put together
like a real or a compilation of a
footage which we were sending to Grants
and four rooms and then we got really
lucky because Teddy and Florian his team
from Rice films found us
at a point late in development and then
they reached out to us and
just really helped us imagine a
different scale for the film in terms of
who else we could collaborate with in
terms of how differently we could
fundraise and that really just began the
process of taking it to a different
level
well I'm glad we did find you and that's
credit to my amazing team at Rise
um and it was I came into the film uh as
a result of an extraordinary
conversation uh with seanack um I'd seen
a clip of some of the stuff that Shawna
and Amman had been filming for the
several months uh prior and then we got
on a zoom early in the pandemic and I
had a sort of a singularly amazing
conversation with a director and I
hadn't really had a conversation like
this in my career where
the specificity of the plan was so clear
and the the ambition for what he wanted
to do
um you know subject to getting the
resource to do it uh was so was so clear
and
impressive and I just you know we just
jumped right in and it was an
extraordinarily
uh difficult uh project to raise money
for because it is so
um extremely execution dependent
um
I mean we got there in the end but it
was a it was it was not easy and I think
that um
it just wasn't an easy one to see the
vision for and I think uh financiers was
scared of it didn't think it was
terribly commercial and just it we
needed to find people sort of
brave enough to go for it which we
eventually did
um
in tangle Bank Studios
um and you know to John's point about
what does a producer do I sort of feel
like I do a different
I fulfill a different role on every film
and on this it was sort of a bit of
everything not I mean I wasn't involved
in the shoot because it was in the midst
of the pandemic I was in London they
were in Delhi
um but
this was a you know this was a project
where I had you know where I was working
with two of the best producers in
children one that I've ever worked with
you know incredibly strategic brilliant
thinkers who made me a better producer
and um yeah I'm just it's a huge honor
to have worked on it
and Sonic I would love the film has such
an incredible visual language that I
know took a while for you to develop we
have these these locked off
um very weighted and grounded shots but
we also have this beautiful panning and
tilting that's almost otherworldly or
um kind of dreamlike and so I'm curious
how you came to develop that visual
language because I know that what we see
on screen is not necessarily the way
that you were shooting the film to begin
with
well for one I think it's a function of
time you just keep shooting
um and we shot for three years and
um
you know like I keep saying that we uh
can I just say I feel like all of us
have heard each other's answers for so
long that we can just answer for each
other uh but we can try that if you want
we can we could actually
let's do it uh Daniel do you want to
take this answer
ah
what was the question again
how did I arrive at the style
the visual style well
should I answer in the first person
I was very interested in exploring this
film cinematically
I wanted to do something that felt like
fiction and I think one of the one of
the most important tools here was time
and and how we massage time and the
patience
and I knew that in order to do this we
would have to utilize the tools of
fiction filmmaking so we see in the
basement a lot of slides a lot of
motivated pans and tilts and it was very
important to us that we just had that
consistent visual style but ultimately
this is a film that takes place on the
lateral on the horizontal we are
enclosed in this basement until we see
the Epic expanse of the Skies of Delhi
and it's those contrasting back and
forths that really empowered and
emboldened our cinematic process
how did he do it is perfect in fact I
was drawing while he was talking
that was perfect I forgot to say the
word modeling that's Sonic's favorite
word
is there anything you wanted to add to
that
no
all right I'm gonna get this back on
track and move to um to all the Beauty
and the Bloodshed and and I and I'm
really curious in um this is more of a
question for Laura but I think
um the group can can answer it as you
see fit
um we do have a Confluence of subjects
we have Nan the artist we have pain and
uh and their activism and their direct
actions and we have a nation in the
throes of an opioid crisis and so I I
think what I gained from watching this
film is just how wonderfully executed uh
how wonderfully woven these three
subjects are together in a way that
feels so cohesive and so I'm I'm curious
how how you all arrived at balancing
those uh those different but also again
converging
subjects and I missed one of the major
subjects of the film which is
my childhood your child in Suburbia and
my sister's suicide yes that's as
important as all the other elements that
you meant correct yes
um you know uh one of our editors Joe
Beanie was actually really instrumental
you know after you know the first stage
of a documentary every documentary gets
to its lock picture in different ways
but one of our first stages was looking
at the footage as Yoni was saying that
the present day footage that Nan and and
Megan and Payne had had shot and also
looking through the archival witnesses
against her Vanishing
um in particular and there was this
amazing footage of Nan organizing the
show of the show itself of David
vonerovich and um I guess I can speak
for Laura to say you know she saw that
sequence and saw in it the heart of so
many other things that we would want to
talk about in the in the film and so at
a certain point
um Joe put together this structure on
paper that interwove all those different
um stories and and that's where that
sort of crafting started and it was
magical
Joe beanie has a history of that he
edited Grizzly Man he added and we need
to talk about Kevin and his way of
editing if we need to talk about Kevin
had been a straight narrative it would
not have had the power that him
withholding things and then we see
something you know he reveals something
and then he withholds and it made it
much more intense and so I feel like he
was the perfect editor for this material
and making chapters with names I mean it
was genius
you know
I think we probably all went through a
variation of this experience is that we
started
really filming intensively and then we
were
hit by the pandemic
and sometimes
the most profound things are the
simplest things
and
Laura had the inspiration of saying like
Okay if we can't film
how do we
keep the life of this film alive and she
said man
I want to come to your apartment and
we'll be safe and socially distanced and
let's just talk
I mean to me
the real organizing principle of this
film is always
Nan's voice
that voice I mean that voice coming
alive
in the film and weaving the political
activism the historical truths the
opioid crisis the AIDS epidemic but
the
profundity of of that moment in post-war
America where
so many assumptions were made that were
so wrong and so crippling and so
devastating
and I don't think we would have ever
gone gotten to that if Laura hadn't said
Nan I want to just come and talk to you
every week
it's a simple thing but it's a huge
thing for this film
I have to you know give a homage to
Laura because she did something
documentary filmmakers don't normally do
which was kept her word about my role in
the film I mean maybe they do but you
know I also know that they don't
sometimes so she gave these she did
these really intensive interviews that
were like you know therapy without a
therapist
and I only did them on the condition
that I would have some control over what
was used and she actually allowed that
which was crucial
for my involvement in the film and my
acceptance of the film and she also
found the primary documents of my I
turned over the primary documents of my
sister's institutional
history and that's where the incredible
title came from
it's from
a Rorschach test that they showed to my
sister and she said I see all the Beauty
and the bloodshed
and I it's an incredible title that
Laura found
absolutely
for the house made of Splinter's team I
want to come back to uh something you
brought up earlier and that's working
with children and this is not as you
mentioned your first film in which
you've had that experience but
specifically in this in this shelter
you possibly weren't sure when how long
you would have with each of these
subjects and so being able to gain their
trust so quickly I just wanted to to ask
you
um how you how you approached that so
empathically
um
that's a very there's a very complicated
answer to this of course but I think for
example one of the more important parts
is that I do my own Cinema
cinematography and my own sound so it's
actually just me and I sat there most of
the time
and I think for both of us we just try
to to to be as honest and as open to the
kids
as we can and being really interested in
seeing them as the small beautiful
beings uh individual beings that they
are their hopes and their dreams and
their fears
um
but also respecting their boundaries
um so you know letting them know that
that if there's something you don't want
us to film you just put up your hand or
say stop or you walk away and in those
incidents where those things happen I'm
I I'm I'm a man of my word so to speak
even if it might be a good scene I still
stop it and over time
I I don't hurry it maybe and that's one
of the reasons also it has to come by
itself that Mutual trust that develops
between us
um kind of become one with the world
that we're almost like we're one of the
staff and the and we spend a lot of time
you know just joking around with the
kids and and understanding everything
about their reality
um so when the more raw emotional
moments happened
to be respectful of that also uh and not
to be too greedy so to speak because as
a documentarist you know you know when
when really important stuff happens it's
so crucial that you capture this but but
I try to remind myself all the time when
this happened to lay down the camera you
know the second I just think I might
have the scene that's when I stopped
filming and I stay behind so that if
they want you know a hug or if they just
want to take a walk or something like
this then I'm also there
yeah I guess that's part part of the end
of the answer yeah yo Yen also we worked
really closely with the caregivers
because you know they've done this for a
lot a long time you know and it's
important to understand how things work
in a place like this and how to
communicate also with the children it's
also very important for example for us
to to set our own barriers you know to
to let them know when we are not here to
adopt you you know to be open and Frank
about these things from the very
beginning
um so they told us a lot uh also to to
to bottle your own feelings when when it
gets tough because what the child needs
is is the adults to to be in some
semblance of of stability and and
control so you can go home and cry later
but for now it's the kids that it's
about their life and their feelings so
be there for them instead yeah
thank you
um and for Sarah and the fire of Love
team
um once you did get access to this
footage
um can you describe a bit the experience
of of just combing through a physical
film archive and I know Maurice
um would say that he wasn't a filmmaker
but he absolutely was and so some of
this footage was conformed into foot
into finished works that he would then
travel with for fundraising
um but what was it like to look through
some of that unconformed footage and
create your own Vision with it
it was absolutely beguiling and
enchanting to look through the craft
archive there was about 200 hours of 16
millimeter footage that Katy and Marie
shot and about and hundreds of thousands
of still photographs that Katya took and
I remember the very first set of images
I saw was from Mauna Loa erupting in
1984 which were downloaded from an FTP
site and kind of the fall of 2020 just
feeling so isolated and alone in those
months of the pandemic and just looking
at them and feeling the lava is alive
like this is truly a sentient being that
I'm seeing here it was so powerful and
it told me so much not just about how
the planet works but also Captain versus
gaze the fact that the Earth was not
something to be conquered it was
something to be centered and celebrated
and it's full and resplendent power and
that course through every image that
they took
um it was extremely challenging though
and my editors Aaron Casper and Johnson
shapu need to be just celebrated and
praised for their extraordinary work
because the imagery it was so beautiful
but it was Aaron often jokes that it
feels like it was put into a blender and
you hit puree so there's like a two
second shot a four second shot a seven
second shot maybe if we're lucky and
often out of order even though there
archival house took beautiful care of
the imagery it was extremely difficult
to piece together
but uh kind of the the complexity and
the at times confusion of what was kind
of laid out for us taught us so much
about how to actually put together the
film we had so many questions you know
why is this shot you know of an erupting
volcano next to a shot of a monitor
lizard eating a dead animal and that
made us realize Kate and Maurice were in
search of these they were asking these
questions themselves this was a film
about meaning and it was a film about
the unknown whether it's about the
unknown forces of our planet or the
unknowns of the human heart and so we
really Embrace that kind of question
asking in our own storytelling and so
what started out as these extreme
challenges became gifts
um so I I could go on and on and on
about those unknowns but do you want to
add anything
that's about as good as it gets uh I
think I think you know just to prove how
slow I am as a processor I will say one
more thing about the producing process
and what what came up uh quite a bit in
uh in our conversation before and I will
tie it back into fire of love just to
give you all the preface of what's going
to happen right now
um
there's there really is a there's a
reflexivity and a relationality to
producing and it's it's an honor to be
here on the stage with everybody because
you know when when we are all trying in
our lives I think to to give what we
have to give in this life and we are
only able to do it thanks to the people
and living beings in this in this world
because you know a producer if their job
is to help a director actualize a vision
needs a vision if there's a vision from
a director they need to help they need
someone who can help them actualize it
um when you have a story like Maurice
and katyas there is this there is this
myth and there is this quest for the
unknown but you need that myth to be
made you need that Quest you need that
story to be told and I think there is an
incredible process and relationship that
emerges when you are going through that
archive because you are even though in
the in our case where we're dealing with
um people who who died almost or over 30
years ago you also have a relationship
with them and you you feel this
incredible sense of connectivity and
where questions are being asked and
answered and there's a there's a
speaking there's a speaking through
place and time and our concepts of life
and death that's really profound and and
meaning is made in that process and so
uh the film that's that's ultimately put
forth exists in this exists forever but
there's also a constant
um
Timeless relationship that's that's
really beautiful in the filmmaking
process
thank you for sharing that and and I am
being given the signal that we are just
about at time but I did have one last
question for the navalny team
and specifically for Daniel if you would
like to answer it I'm just so curious
um about you know this is a question I
wish I had time to ask everyone but
unfortunately we are short for time
um when we talk about filmmaking
especially in the past 15 years or so we
talk a lot about impact and and the
impact that a film can have uh in in
society right
um but what I'm curious is less about
sort of the broad message or the social
impact of the film that you've made and
more what you hope your audience takes
away from the film when they've seen it
what is that the small sort of piece of
of
inspiration or
um or activism that you hope a single
person in your audience will take away
with them after they've seen your film
well this is a very serious question or
otherwise I would have thrown it over to
seanick
but I think I'll I'll answer that
you know when we released this film when
it premiered the war started three weeks
later or the escalation rather of the
war and what we had was this what we
thought was a prescient film and it was
just thrusted to a new level of
relevance and importance and ultimately
as we worked hard and fast to get this
film out into the world
it was motivated by the understanding
that navalny remained in peril
we made a film
excuse me that doesn't have a happy
ending
right now alexay navalny is in a little
cell that's that's two meters by three
meters he's essentially being tortured
in prison and it's clear that the
Kremlin is trying to break his body Mind
and Spirit they're trying to murder him
slowly
and
I had a great I felt a great deal of
guilt associated with that
because here I was taking this film
around the world getting to go to so
many extraordinary places
and it's predicated on this guy who I
cared about languishing in these
torturous conditions and that was very
challenging But ultimately we understood
that navalny was going to go back to
Russia no matter what
but by being there and bearing witness
we had no delusions that that that we
would create a structural change or get
him
out of Russia you know Laura poitrus
who's such an inspiration for me so
often talks about the limitations of
filmmaking films ability to make
structural changes but in spite of that
we understood that keeping the bonding
in the global Consciousness mattered
keeping his family in the global
Consciousness and his plight and his
mission in the global Consciousness
mattered so I think more than anything I
I hope that our film what it's achieved
is keeping navalny's name and plight
reverberating throughout the world
and and my Ultimate Dream and aspiration
is that one day in the hypothetical
Russia of the future
When Vladimir Putin is no longer the
president and this war is over
um I can go to Moscow and I can rent a
cinema and I can show a Lexar movie
and that's my my dream for the for the
future and what I really hope to do one
day
thank you all so much for joining us
today I really wish we had more time I
have so many more questions for each and
every one of you
um but I want to thank you again for
being here and congratulate you all on
your nomination for an Academy Award
um I look forward to seeing you uh on
Sunday and
um and I hope you all enjoy the rest of
your evening and again thank you so much
for being here and thank you to our
audience for joining for this
conversation today
[Applause]